alors tu en parlant de johnny hallyday
sur un stade c'est toujours l'amour fou
entre jalil lespert et lætitia ligne je
me tourne vers bernard montiel parce que
c'est le spécialiste des coupes une ce
petit plus il est désormais leurs
relations sous le soleil à malibu où ils
ont emménagé ensemble les embrasse
d'ailleurs oui c'est bien il paraît que
laeticia hallyday qui est très amoureuse
n'a pas hésité à faire une concession
pour prouver son amour à jalil qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait c'est à dire que comme je
l ai parlé l'autre jour elle a vendu
vous savez la maison de pacific
palissades à peu près 12 millions
d'euros 14 15 millions de dollars et que
du coup elle a reloué de maison même
ouais ouais alors au lieu de maisons non
comme l'autre maison de pacific
palissades jeu parce que la conduite oui
elle était très grande y avait dix
salles de bains etc enfin bon elle a
vendu les meubles avaient de quoi se
laver compte y avait de quoi cela
fascine mais la piscine war kids qui
dominé cette forêt c'est assez joli mais
stéphane plaza on peut penser qu'elle
elle vend effectivement les meubles mais
c'est alors elles vont les halles a
décidé d'abandonner tous les meubles
choisis oui par johnny voire aux ménages
et avec quel vent avec les meubles non
non c'est clair qu'à a vendu la maison à
part si vous même devant les meubles
parce que la maison qu'elle a pris
maintenant il aimait beaucoup plus petit
mais il ya toujours eu de meubles est
trop de meubles alors à mon avis les
meubles c'est pas beau bécaud à robeco
très beaux meubles qui était faite sur
mesure à l'époque
et puis il ya bien des telle
appréciation ou mais son amour à jalil
pour que voilà on change les bobs moi je
peux comprendre je prends comprenant
vrai que je peux au moins lui qui au
début j'ai cru que ça allait trop vite
entre eux qu'ils communiquaient trop
vite sur leur couple à ça fait des mois
ça semble être vraiment sérieux donc
c'est normal qu'elle veuille faire son
deuil et moi je me mets à sa place c'est
normal aussi c'est bien que non mais
l'amour et le souvenir ne se joue pas
sur une table basse et un guéridon donc
en fait elle a quand même de l'amour
pour dieu sait de qui c'est pas comme ça
lance jean-claude hiquet est en fait il
faut lui [ __ ] la paix en fait
simplement et quel point le refasse sa
vie et elle passe à autre chose et tout
va bien et ça n'enlève en rien l'amour
absolu qu'elle a eu pour johnny le père
relou comptait le faire qu'on aille a le
plus roulé mais pas compliqué de faire
table rase du passé quand même basse et
des symboles des souvenirs moi je suis
un peu choqué quand même de faire ça
vous regardez les maples au soutien
garde inverse ci s'était installé dans
une maison il y avait des meubles de
johnny tout le monde aurait dit c'est
indécent il s'installe alors que c'est à
johnny non
voilà il faut savoir effectivement dire
adieu au passé à s'installer avec lui il
a fait une vidéo il n'y a pas longtemps
une photo où il conduit le cabriolet de
johnny ils se sont fait insulter de tous
les noms j'en vois là il change un peu
et apparemment il a fait sa demande en
mariage
non ah oui oui il après sa demande ya
trois semaines qu'il fait mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe quoi qu est-ce qu après ski
c'est bien d'avancer je trouve moi
qu'est ce qu'il ya la presse écrite
c'est bien d'avancer l'instant il n'y a
pas de demande en mariage non non ce que
généralement avant de faire une demande
en mariage les gens que j'ai pas peur de
lui taper dessus quand il faut là je
vais vous dire moi je suis très heureux
pour elle et ils sont très heureux c'est
très con devant les meubles c'est normal
en revanche que d'apporter une précision
sur l'esplanade géniale idée les avis
dont on a beaucoup parlé alors c'est toi
laurent après ce à compter de ce devait
être le 15 juin qui fait qu'ils
célébraient hier johnny le 78ème
anniversaire de johnny sur l'esplanade
de l'accord arena vous savez est en fait
c est repoussée au 14 septembre
ils se trompent dans la presse y met
toujours 15 septembre et il ya eu neuf
blocs 7,14 ce n'est pas 15
voilà la gageure a plus rien donc si on
donne aucun c'est le 14e la mardis et
samedis comme des cons la pièce
émissions de télévision en hommage à
johnny produite par anne marcassus aux
jambes rassad-1 l'embrasser il y aura un
bateau extraordinaire était très
angoissée à n'en plus pour cette
histoire l'école hors contrat serait une
trahison et vrac
oui l'été est où ça les patrons et les
étudiants elle pense à eux je fais de
gros bisous à gré et ça y est j espère
qu elle est rassurée avec les nouvelles
qui a donné tant de la famille et vous
avez d'ailleurs fait beaucoup agi pour
ça et je voulais dire qu'elle simplement
lèvres qui va être offerte ce jour là
c'est une oeuvre assez tôt 30
c'est quoi je sais pas si ça va plaire
ils ont suspendu enfin ils vont bientôt
l'un installé une harley davidson bleus
ouais tout en haut d'un pic pas mal
c'est pas à moi ça me plaît mais moi je
crois que les jambes risquent de vouloir
grimper peut-être pour l'art et
emmerdent pas des chats n'était pas
ministre de l'intérieur que tu nous fais
chier
vous allez voir c'est aujourd'hui aux
quatre ce serait une bonne idée présente
bien ils vont mettre ça bah oui c'est
comme le manche d'une guitare comme ça
est en hausse et une noire les bleus
c'est pas vrai car les bleus cents par
titre qu'il a créé ah ouais et c est ça
y est c'est le faire qu'est pas connu un
d'accord merci pied par nicolas boyer
voilà bernard montiel sont immolés voilà
il vient pas pour rien
[Applaudissements]